AAAAAAAAAaaaaaAAAAAaaAaAaA!!!
WELCOME TO LWIAY, Roll the Intro
*epic LWAIY intro*
Hello everyone to everyone's favorite part of the year!
Uhh. Week!
(song joins in the back) LWIAY, everyone!
LWIAY
Let's (clap) just (clap) jump into it, Ok?
I'm ready (Are you sure Pewds?)
What have they posted on the Reddit this time?
YouTube did an oopsie!
NINJA, did an oopsie!
*NiNjA being a salty boi*
WELCOME, NINJA! (to the world of demonetization)
*angelic choir*
Welcome, Ninja! This is how it feels like! (soon enough you get some COPYRIGHT STRIKES REEEE)
Confusion
Anger
Hatred
Just don't let it build up inside you.
Towards some other channels
and ethnicities (?)
I don't know why I added ethnic- okay. *Silly Pewds doesn't know why he said "ethnicities"*
LET'S MOVE ON!
(clap) manga
Anime..
(skratta) Netflix adaptation XD
Well *gosh darn* (christian channel)
(more skratta-ing)
It looks strangely good, I-I feel like I actually did a good job on that edit. (sure Pewds)
even got the *texture* I mean, COME ON
I should've made the shirt more dirty. (Pewds slaps himself, oh no)
I D I O T
It bothers me as well how they didn't center the *friccin* image, like
Jesus Christ dude (Don't use the christian channel name in vain Pewds)
Sooooome body (once?) told me "IT'S REWIND TIME EVERYBODY!"
I just realized if I sing the so- (something like a burp?) I might get demonetized. (ono)
*some kid on Reddit lul*
Fun Fact: That's how I got started on YouTube. (Oh)
*stutters* I literally - the first (piece?) of money I ever made EVER. (Whoa)
I just bought a computer XD (More skratta-ing)
I guess you could say it's probably the best investment of my life (that's sad Pewds) to be honest (skratta)
*darn*
And here it is ?Bethan? as I call her
Very niceeeeee
(Bethan???) *darn* I was so proud of her. (awwww)
That graphics card, very cheap, but very powerful. (Oooooooh like GFuel use code Pewdiepie and buy the chair for $399 pls he's desperate)
I don't remember what it was called
*Gosh darn* That takes me back man, Jesus Christ
Yeah, I always grew up on laptops cuz my family just wanted laptops for whatever reason. (Their not epic gamers like you Felix)
But that feeling *mwah* when you buy your very first desktop
*More hand kissing?*
Aint nothin like it *aggressive Pewds noise* No no no
*Reddit meme*
*PAPAYES* And it was EPIC (skratta)
Did you see the meme about the (don't say it Felix) DEER (dammit)
*More memes*
*sad Justin Roiland*
*slamming desk* (what did the desk ever do to you?) AM. I. A JO-
Well you were a surprise though, to be fair.
*struggles with Justin's name*
Although you have never expressed anything.... at all.
But there you go!
*ELON CHANGED HIS BIO!!!!! OMG*
Famous for hosting Meme Review once.
Now, I saw this meme before, and yes, I did check.
And yes I was disappointed. But then I realized maybe he had it at one point.
When no one noticed.
Our final battle against T-series.
𝔉𝔯𝔦𝔡𝔞𝔶𝔰 𝔴𝔦𝔱𝔥 𝔓𝔢𝔴𝔡𝔦𝔢𝔭𝔦𝔢.
*lil gasp* Oh god...
You know it's still ticking. And *gosh darn* it, is it close.
It wouldn't surprise me, actually, if they-
Oh god, maybe they passed. Oh god, I just realised, [by the time] this video goes up, they're going to pass.
Well, I still have 𝔉𝔯𝔦𝔡𝔞𝔶𝔰 𝔴𝔦𝔱𝔥 𝔓𝔢𝔴𝔡𝔦𝔢𝔭𝔦𝔢.
几乇ᐯ乇尺 Ꮆ丨ᐯ乇 ㄩ卩  ʕ·ᴥ·　ʔ
Should I run for president?
Like, these fake Elon tweets, it's like, "Yeah it's fake, right? Is it fake?"
(Real 𝑒𝓁𝑜𝓆𝓊𝑒𝓃𝓉.)
"Did he do that?"
That's why Elon's so interesting. 'Cause you never know. You never know what he's gonna do.
*reads post*
I couldn't agree more. TOO BAD. It's a bureaucratic issue right now. We're trying to figure it out.
But don't hold your breath, guys. Don't hold your breath.
*reads post*
"treat people the way you want to be treated."
You want copystrike? XD
WE GOT THEM (yes we do)
Here in India I made a class
presentation, oh god *owo* you made a class presentation on why PewDiePie is loved and how media
criticizes him. Teacher loved it, by the
way this is first time I'm posing here.
Well welcome Murphy 141 and I see here
you says in 1.8 metres which is exactly
my height by the way so I appreciate
that you didn't bring up media lies okay.
"Elon Musk when he sees a meme about
himself"
"Elon Musk when he sees a dead deer"
I think you get one strike warning. It's just like the strike system.
oh they're hilarious, and then you see
them over yourself Felix Smellberg (ノ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)ノ︵┻┻
it's not funny, OKAY?!?! it really isn't funny, it's just cringy, I get it it's what I'm
saying I understand
Elon-san.
make fun of it oh I thought beds are on
my own audience. *angery slam*
You want fOrTnItE? we got it. (oh yes)
You want some minecraft? Easy. This channel is
still relevant. *well played*
BOTS, I mean I can't be in it there's no
way look there's bots, look there even is
a robot there I think point proven
okay? I have a trick up my sleeve and
it's coming okay you best be scared T
series, if it's not all up already keep
an eye out, because you're gonna die okay
that's not a threat that's just a fact
everyone's gonna die at some point.
saying I understand
Elon san.
Moving on, anime pewds:
This is so insensitive okay, just because I don't have legs it doesn't have to mean you
make fun of it oh I thought beds are on
my own audience. *angery slam*
Felix isn't our child beautiful? *uwu*
To the ranch. (▀̿Ĺ̯▀̿ ̿)
*???*
They must fight for survival.
You want fortnight? we got it. (oh yes)
Oh you're into
roblox huh? We got you covered baby.  (͡° ͜ʖ ͡ -)
You want some minecraft? Easy. This channel is
still relevant. *well played*
Even though, T-series, I just realized has clearly passed me, how
did they get such a boost? BOTS, it's just
BOTS, I mean I can't be in it there's no
way look there's bots, look there even is
a robot there I think point proven
okay? I have a trick up my sleeve and
it's coming okay you best be scared T
series, if it's not all up already keep
an eye out, because you're gonna die okay
that's not a threat that's just a fact
everyone's gonna die at some point.
T-series actually good save, actually
surpasses Felix for a short time,
meaning that Felix became number one
twice! *HAHAHA* Just wanted to make it a little
extra Guinness World Records, no big deal, no big deal at all.
If you're subscribe to T-series reply.
PETA: Thanks for your support!
Complete your donation now. (uh no thanks)
YAY! Free reddit karma! Did that actually
happen well-played, shaymin.
Oh Lushsux, goddamn that is kind of
uncomfortable but thank you very much Lushsux, as always.
Give Lushsux some
love, link in the description, he does awesome work you should follow him.
Oh here's a good one, Elon Musk hosting meme review gave us a new meme format. *clap* *clap*
It gave us plenty of new format let's get real here, plus even recorded in front of a
green screen, ABSOLUTE MAD LADS.
*heh heh heh*
Pewdiepie: I am one of the smartest
intellectuals on the planet. True straight-up facts.
There is actually a
film based on this movie.
Now, I gotta give myself credit for not just saying this, not just for slipping through side
editing it but also slipping through me
and doing a second edit on it and then
also sleeping through me for time
watching it until someone points it on
the comments that's how much of an
intellectual I am thank you very much
If you remember this, you qualify for a
veteran's discount, oh god we were
actually a million ahead at one point
where are we now. Oh, I gotta look at it
it doesn't matter, I don't care about
numbers by the way I really it doesn't
really matter like numbers doesn't mean anything to me.
It could be 50 billion, it could be five.
I don't care who's counting right? who's counting?
My brother and I did our part at
the WWE Smackdown. "SUB 2 PewDiePie"
Well played, you and your brother. Very nice, I want to do something to summarize
everything that you guys have done like
I don't know like a video cuz there's so
many crazy parts or legendary photos
that I've seen I would love to put that
together somewhere when T series passes
no they will never my main man Shara TV
got his video of him singing to a
hamster yeah they monetized I mean that
seems worthy of G monetization don't you
know children could watch that video I
need to see this video but then again
then I might get demonetised well to be
fair he hasn't hit quite
review and I'm sure if he does there
will actually but then again I would
like to know if he did that and did it
still get the monetize now me attack
reverse uno I don't have legs T gate
hurt itself and it's well played by me
thank you very much myself okay this man
is 77 years old has been uploading for
12 years
no way and he has only 131 subscribers
he uploads every week he's a critic and
reviews all the movies oh god I gotta
check this out Jackie
K Jack checked yet oh look they already
subscribed and you made a thank you nine
you're all are we already at 44,000
through the subreddit M you have amazing
quality of camera how did it get such
amazing clothing how does people have
You want copystrike? XD
"treat people the way you want to be treated."
WE GOT THEM (yes we do)
Oh your into demonitization to?!!? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
WE GOT YOU COVERED BABYYYY
This joke is STILL relevant!!! *clap clap*
*ha ha ha*
So, I think she's okay. (uhh no)
I mean it's true I was kind of expecting
Moving on, anime pewds:
This is so insensitive okay, just because I don't have legs it doesn't have to mean you
Felix isn't our child beautiful? *uwu*
To the ranch. (▀̿Ĺ̯▀̿ ̿)
*???*
They must fight for survival.
Oh you're into
roblox huh? We got you covered baby.  (͡° ͜ʖ ͡ -)
Even though, T-series, I just realized has clearly passed me, how
did they get such a boost? BOTS, it's just
T-series actually good shape actually